well residents of kiev remain under a
curfew as battles continue between
ukrainian and russian forces joining us
now from ukraine's capital is associated
press reporter joe fetterman joe thanks
for joining us just tell us how fierce
the fighting is tonight and where it's
concentrated
yeah we're here in central kiev the
capitol and it is eerily quiet it has
been quiet for most of the day very
little fighting here in the capital
it seems that the heaviest fighting is
just outside of kiev about 30 kilometers
20 miles uh outside of the city uh it
seems that the russian advance has
stopped at least temporarily
inside the city we do have air raid
sirens about an hour ago we had another
one and just a few moments ago we heard
some gunfire off in the distance so
there is some unrest in the city but for
the most part it feels like a ghost town
all right kiev's mayor extended that
overnight curfew until monday morning
in order to prevent residents from being
mistaken for russian saboteurs what does
he mean by saboteurs
yes they believe that there are elements
within ukraine's own population who are
sympathetic to the russian cause if you
remember ukraine was part of the soviet
union has a long history uh with russia
it has its own russian-speaking uh
minority um and they believe that there
are people within the population who are
assisting uh the russian forces so
they're trying to use this time now it's
about 36 hours of complete closure uh to
track down and what they say that some
of these units actually disguise
themselves they wear ukrainian uniforms
and so forth so they're using this
coming period 36 hours to track down
these so-called saboteurs
all right president zielenski has
appeared in another video
to show that he remains in kiev despite
the russian advances he also turned down
a u.s offer to evacuate and according to
ukraine's embassy in london zolensky
said the fight is here i need ammunition
not a ride
how long can president zielenski hold
out do you think
yeah that's a question
i can't give you an answer i can't
predict the future what i can tell you
is if you would ask me this yesterday i
would have given you a different answer
yesterday it felt like the russian army
was just closing in on the city and it
was a matter of time before everything
collapsed today it feels like the tide
has turned a bit it seems that the
ukrainian military is putting up quite
the fight putting up some stiff
resistance that's why it's so quiet in
the city uh and zielinski i think is one
of the reasons for this uh he has
remained in the city he has resisted
calls to flee he's making videos in his
office he's sticking with his people and
i think that's i think that's helping
motivate
his forces how long they can continue
this it's impossible to say but the uh
the performance of the ukrainian
military i think is a lot stronger than
what people had thought uh it might have
been
and president zielenski uh setting quite
an example for his people all right
thanks for that associated press
reporter joe fetterman joining us once
again